[Musica]
identità
quante volte avete sentito questa parola
e quante volte
oggi pomeriggio la sentirete ancora ma
avete mai fatto caso che questa parola
rimane sempre identica che la usiamo al
singolare o al plurale non cambia mai
adesso forse qualcuno di voi dentro di
sé sta pensando ma in fondo l'identità è
un concetto essenzialmente singolare
almeno sul piano giuridico
ciascuno di noi non può che avere una e
una sola identità al singolare
e in effetti quando dobbiamo
autenticarci di fronte ad un autorità di
fronte a una controparte pubblica
privata nazionale straniera ci basta
estrarre la nostra carta d'identità
il nostro passaporto ed ecco che ci
identifichiamo in modo incontrovertibile
lo stesso accade se dobbiamo noleggiare
un'auto o acquistare una bottiglia di
vino e dobbiamo dimostrare al nostro
interlocutore che siamo maggiorenni e
tutto molto semplice quando però ci
spostiamo dall'universo analogico
all'universo digitale e le cose cambiano
cambiano radicalmente
qui non abbiamo più una sola identità
personale
ma tante identità digitali da facebook
ad amazon da booking l'agenzia delle
entrate all'inps e chi più ne ha più ne
metta
tutti ci chiedono di eleggere delle
credenziali di sceglierci un nome utente
e una password
insomma ci assegna
loro un'identità digitale
ora se è vero ed è vero che ciascuno di
noi utilizza decine di queste
piattaforme di queste applicazioni e se
è vero che la sicurezza informatica ci
obbliga a scegliere oramai delle
combinazioni alfanumeriche
difficilissime
io vi chiedo come possiamo ricordare
tutte queste password no non lo so
certamente molto difficile
qualcuno avrà una lista ma certo è
complicato ed è così complicato che sarà
successo anche a voi a volte di
rinunciare ad utilizzare un servizio
digitale pur di non aggiungere
l'ennesima password al vostro elenco
oppure dove è possibile
scegliete di loggarvi con altro
operatore
in effetti sono sempre di più i siti che
consapevoli della difficoltà di gestire
tutte queste identità digitali ci
offrono la possibilità di identificarci
facendo leva su password rilasciate da
altro operatore
vorrei caso d'uso sicuramente più noto
di identità federata e lo speed lo speed
è il sistema pubblico di identità
digitale con lo speed un'unica password
noi possiamo accedere ai servizi
digitali di tutte le pubbliche
amministrazioni italiane ed anche delle
imprese aderenti in italia e all'estero
e complice lockdown lo speed ha avuto un
successo clamoroso
in pochi mesi sono state superate i 10
milioni di utenze e questo è un
bellissimo segnale per il nostro paese
per la digitalizzazione
ma anche per la sua indipendenza perché
portare i nostri dati su server italiani
significa ridurre lo strapotere dei
colossi statunitensi e il rischio che
questi abusino dei nostri dati e quindi
ben venga lo speed
ma ora io vi dico non sarebbe fantastico
se potessimo ricongiungere la nostra
identità personale e digitale se
potessimo dimenticare tutte le password
anche quella dello speed ed essere solo
claudia anche online
sto sognando non lo so ma le parole
block chain sales of identity identità
autogestita vi dicono niente
no non sto non stiamo pensando di
abolire la sovranità statale ci
mancherebbe ma l'idea che c'è sotto la
senso verna identità è geniale semplice
ma geniale ed è questa ogni individuo a
una e una sola identità e l'identità e
la proiezione di me e quindi l'identità
non può che appartenere all'individuo
rappresentato chi dunque ne deve poter
disporre liberamente senza bisogno di
intermediari e la block chain serve
proprio a questo
attraverso la blog chain infatti quella
per capirci dei bitcoin non serviranno
più password ogni volta che un'autorità
immetterà nella rete distribuita un
certificato qualunque controparte potrà
verificare che quel certificato proviene
da una certa autorità che quel
certificato è autentico ed integro
come nella realtà analogica mi
identifico con un certificato così lo
stesso certificato potrà essere
utilizzato nella realtà digitale
ma c'è di più e per capirlo facciamo
torniamo un attimo all'esempio di prima
dicevamo che quando dobbiamo noleggiare
un'auto acquistare una bottiglia di vino
dobbiamo dimostrare la nostra maggiore
età e che semplicemente ci basta esibire
la nostra carta d'identità ma avete mai
pensato che facendo così voi date il
vostro interlocutore molti più dati di
quelli che vi ha chiesto nella mia carta
d'identità terrore era la mia residenza
troverà il mio stato civile
tutti i dati che non mi erano stati
chiesti ma non lo sapete che i dati sono
preziosi che vanno custoditi con cura
ebbene con l'assenso vern identity anche
questo problema potrebbe essere risolto
come immaginate per un secondo che la
vostra identità sia come un mazzo di
carte
ad ogni carta corrisponde un attributo
la data di nascita lo stato civile
il titolo di studio e avanti così
ebbene con la sales overnight entity il
mazzo lo tiene ciascun soggetto ognuno
di noi terrà il proprio mazzo e allora
quando dovrà autenticarsi di fronte a
una controparte potrà decidere quali
carte giocare quali dati condividere con
quella parte potrà creare sulla base
della circostanza sulla base
dell'affidabilità della sua controparte
un certificato ad hoc più o meno ricco
tagliato su misura
ma siamo seri ci vorrà ancora molto
tempo perché questo sistema possa essere
operativo ci attendono grandi sfide
forse più giuridiche che tecniche
ma nel frattempo tutti noi impegniamoci
a vincere le resistenze verso le
tecnologie emergenti
e allora così un giorno non troppo
lontano potremo finalmente dire di avere
una e una sola identità anche digitale
al singolare
[Musica]